so for now what I'm going to write is
taking those two beer emerges to
indicate to my natural log is two times
e so I'm just gonna write to it like so
okay so I've done the boundaries and now
I'm going to have a look at the
integrand here the thing being
integrated so I've got my Peter that's
an E and here's the first appearance of
the ice cream emoji which I said at the
start I was going to denote with an X so
I write an X there then you've got this
differential operator DX yeah
well part of a differential operator
anyway and then the answer to this is
the solution to the puzzle so what's
this equal to now the reason why the
second line of the puzzle goes to such
lengths to arrive at this special number
E is because e to the X is a special
exponential it is a function whose
derivative and by you know sort of
comparison with that it's integral is
itself when you differentiate e to the X
you get e to the X and if you integrate
e to the X it'll be e to the X plus a
constant okay so it's a very special
function the vast majority functions out
there don't do this so when I integrate
e to the X my primitive function is e to
the X this is a definite integral that's
why I don't need to worry about the
constant of integration for those of you
following one at home and then I'm going
to evaluate it at the bottom and the top
limits so log e and log to e now some of
you will be asking any why did you not
simplify the natural log of e that's the
log base a of a that's just equal to 1
well I could but as you'll see in a
second it doesn't end up helping us very
much or it's just as useful to leave it
in its current form let me show you why
the next step now that I've got the
primitive function of integrated is I
need to evaluate at the top boundary so
track that from the bottom boundary so
I'm gonna get e to the power of log 2e
that's the upper boundary for X and I'm
going to subtract that from e to the
power of just regular log a so this is
now what I need to evaluate now at this
point here if I had
suited log e2b equalling to one log a
equals one the natural log of e I should
say then this last little part of the
expression e to the power of log e would
just be e whoops didn't mean my
highlighter there would just be e to the
power of one so that's just eat no big
deal it is indeed that but that doesn't
help you so much with this first part of
the expression this guy over here you
can't do it so neatly so what do we do
with them now in order to solve this I'm
just gonna take a slight step to one
side let's choose a different color like
orange here and I'm gonna explain how we
can deal with this e to the power of log
something okay
so you can actually say if Y if I had a
to the power of anything you like let's
call it u okay let's just focus on this
for a second
what would this be equal to well again
supposing I don't know what this what
value it should take let's just give it
another name let's just call it K what
we want to do is find out what K is but
now that I've written an equation I can
actually work with both sides of this
and I can I can do some manipulation it
helps me determine the value of K so
let's have a goat this if I say e to the
log u equals K the first thing that
comes to my mind is I want to get that
log you out of the index it's a couple
of ways you could do this you could
rewrite this exponential equation all in
terms of logs but you get to be
confusing for some people when they see
the next line which would just be log
base a of K equals log u that's the
definition of a logarithm on the basis
of an exponential equation so this is
true but I'm just gonna pull it to one
side because there might be another
easier way to argue it even though it's
going to take slightly more working but
people generally when I show this term
especially my students they're happier
with this argument than they are with
the one that I just showed you what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take logs of
both slides and then move this over a
little bit if I take logs of both sides
I'm gonna get a natural log of e to the
log U on the left and then on the right
hand side I'll get the natural log of K
so far so good I'm going to use the
other power law or the index law that
some of you might be from
with logs to take this let's use a
different color here so take this log
you over here and I can move that at the
front it becomes the coefficient so log
you at the front times log of whatever
is remaining once I take that index away
which in this case is the e so that
equals log K let's move the service
that's all nice and neat alright now a
minute or two ago I mentioned that log a
the natural log of a is just 1 so on the
left hand side if that's just 1 I just
get left with log U and that's equal to
log K so this clearly shows that you and
K have to be identical so if I go back
to my original line here instead of
writing either the log u equals K since
K is U I can say e to the log U is just
u so e to the power of log something is
just that something whatever's inside
that log function and now I'm ready to
come back to our original puzzle over
here now that I've got this all written
in place
what's my U in this case well the first
one my U is to e so e to the power of
log to e is just to E and then when I
have a look on the next one I say this
is e to the power of log
what's my U in this case all the U in
this case is e so here to the log E as
we saw before is just a single eight so
- E - E that gives a solution of a that
I think is what the author of this
puzzle was intending so the answer as is
often the case in life is pizza now I
did promise that if I solved this puzzle
for the 1 plus 1 equals 2 version of the
answer then I would also do it for these
other two solutions well let's quickly
eat address each one if I have a look at
this first one here if the two beers are
just equal to 1 then what you've really
got here is you've got natural log of e
on the lower boundary and then if you
have a look at the top boundary well if
it's 1 times a pizza that's 1 times e
then the top
also log e now if one of the properties
of a definite integral is if you
integrate from one place to itself and
you're not integrating over any interval
you're actually just integrating from
somewhere to itself so you actually get
a value of zero that would be the
solution that you get it here in the
question mark which I guess would be
true but not particularly satisfying
it's like wow I can't believe I did all
that work and i just got zero okay so
that's what happens if you take two
beers to equal one what happens if you
take two beers two equal eleven well
it's not too difficult to follow the
argument if you have a look and see
everyone wherever I wrote to which came
from the two beers if I replace every
two with an eleven then you're going to
see the result fall out fairly quickly
so the first let's replace it with a
green eleven there's the first
replacement here it comes up again
because I'm evaluating the top boundary
here is another appearance that becomes
an eleven and then finally I have an 11
here well 11 a minus a I guess is 10 a
which again also is true it's no easier
or harder than when I solved it for if
two beers were equal to 2 but 10 E is is
not as elegant and beautiful and nice as
a surprise to the honest a as the answer
10 pizzas rather than one pizza I think
it's nicer to say this solution is just
one of them so anyway I hope you enjoyed
that puzzle thanks for playing along and
yeah next time you encounter one of
these do pay close attention in the
maths but if you wanna get the answer
right pay close attention to the emojis